and finally new rule before leaving this
election behind we must all thank Donald
Trump for the one good thing he did he
exposed of Angelico's who are big Trump
supporters as the shameless hypocrites
they've always been
I don't know if you notice but
Republicans didn't get to play the Jesus
card this time around because it's hard
to bring up the Ten Commandments when
your candidate spent his life breaking
all of them Trump's Commandments are
like the regular Commandments with lol
at the end adultery
check cursing this is you [ __ ]
check stealing check bearing false
witness wrong check false idols oh yeah
he is the world's least godly man Jesus
so the good and [ __ ] and lepers but if
he met Donald Trump he'd go sorry man
that's a pre-existing condition
so with four days left in this longest
election ever I'm gonna stop for a
minute and appreciate this one silver
lining that for once religion wasn't
dragged into the debate after so many
elections where the candidates tried to
out Jesus each other this one had no
talk from either candidate about how
they start their morning with Scripture
the Republican wasn't reaching out to
his prayer warriors the debate
moderators weren't asking how does faith
inform your decisions and best of all we
were spared the sight of having to watch
Hillary Clinton try and clap on the beat
with a black church choir
[Applause]
but I still think we are owed an
explanation from the Values Voters as to
how they could line up behind Trump a
man who loves to say nobody loves the
Bible more than I do but when asked
couldn't name a single passage even
Sarah Palin said Oh for [ __ ] sake it's
not a newspaper Trump tried to quote
scripture once and called second
Corinthians 2 Corinthians as in 2
Corinthians walk into a bar he also once
accepted Jesus Christ as his personal
Lord and Taylor then Brett P Trump has
nothing in common with Jesus who was
from the Middle East Trump wouldn't even
let him in the country jesus healed the
blind Trump mocks the handicapped Jesus
turned the other cheek
Trump grabs your [ __ ] Jesus turned
water into wine Trump just wines the
Bible says thou shalt not covet thy
neighbor's wife Trump says fine what
about my daughter
he did he's the devil
what part of pleased to meet you hope
you guess my name don't you understand
in the primaries of Angelico's had a
whole bouquet of religious nuts to
choose from Mike Huckabee Rick Santorum
Scott Walker Ted Cruz Ben Carson ben
Carson who doesn't just walk with Jesus
they shower together
[Applause]
but they went for the foul-mouthed
thrice-married [ __ ] grabber with one
exception and I never thought I would
hear myself say this but let's hear it
for the Mormons the Mormons who bailed
on Trump Bigley white evangelicals go
for Trump over Hillary 75 to 14 but only
19% of Utah Mormons have a favorable
view of orange it ler because apparently
the Mormons believe you shouldn't vote
for a lying infantile scumbag just
because he's on your team and they're
Mormons don't believe almost anything
they believe underwear has magic powers
and you get your own planet when you die
and Adam and Eve were born in Missouri
and Jesus hung with the Indians who were
Jewish they let Donny Osmond claim he's
a little bit rock and roll but ask one
if Trump would make a good president and
they're like do I look like I was born
yesterday